welcome back to the gadget lab podcast
I'm Mike Isaac I'm Michael colori and
this week in the news what do we have
going on like ah let's see there was a
apology letter from netflix that arrived
in my inbox and it couldn't quite make
much set up with what did it say we're
sorry that we jacked up the prices so
we're splitting into two companies
basically yeah so you know in case in
case you've been living under a rock the
baby streaming service Netflix had a
change of business a couple of months
ago where they were splitting up the DVD
subscriptions in the streaming
subscriptions apparently people who
couldn't read things and understand them
were confused by this so the company has
done even more drastic business change
right they they literally spun off their
physical DVD mail away service into an
entirely separate company called a quick
stir which is harkening back to the days
of Napster and I've seen like how many
different people making fun of the name
I don't know the name is neither here
there but basically they're going to
operate both businesses separately and
it's sort of like everyone's kind of
speculating is it a strategic move to to
sort of put more emphasis on streaming
only instead of you know physical dvds
so if one side of the business does
poorly over time they don't have to
worry about upsetting shareholders I
think so I think that's the that's the
tack I mean basically it's it's pretty
obvious at this point that Netflix wants
DVDs to just disappear right its
customers aren't quite necessarily sure
that they want to give up dvds because
either they don't how they aren't set up
for streaming or they have an
experienced streaming or there's also
the fact that Netflix is streaming kind
of the content options that they make
available for streaming are less than
what's available for DVD or they're
living in the Stone Age and you're not
in the future yeah so Netflix is trying
to sort of uh sure its business into the
next step and there
kind of a tough go of it yeah I mean
everyone is just kind of like confused
like they got this sort of weird email
in their inbox on monday morning the
company broke this news like wait sunday
yeah everyone just wakes up to this like
what is this new company yeah the thing
I think I don't really the thing I can't
get behind is people complaining that
it's you know costing them money you're
consuming content at a rate you know
five times what you say will consume it
at so just get over it and pay the money
whatever dude I want more for less yeah
everybody does right back but the other
the other news that we have is a gadget
piece of gadgetry we actually have
hardware tell me about it Mike it's
that's why I'm here hmm what is it this
is a new android tablet yeah never seen
one of these before I bet this is
actually one that's it's the second
tablet we've seen this year from Lenovo
the company that makes a thinkpad and
this is actually the thinkpad tablet so
it's branded like all the other thinkpad
laptops that are pretty common in
corporate workspaces and favored by
business travelers ubiquitous red dot
yes you're pointing at this which is
also stylist this is optional it's a
five-hundred-dollar tablet and that's
for Wi-Fi only and it comes with
everything that you would expect a
five-hundred-dollar Wi-Fi tablet has
come with it's got a gig of ram it's
getting gigahertz processor it's got a
nice big screen it also has some heft
it's about a pound and a half it has
physical hdmi and USB ports it has a lot
of the stuff that we've seen some of the
more business-minded tablets have it the
stylus is 30 bucks which is not it's not
about HTC debut their tablet with a
stylus and like 80 bucks yeah the flyer
ebert right and it actually goes into
the to the tablet itself yes and a
triple a battery goes inside of the
stylist don't ask me why I'm with
batteries are batteries not included the
battery is included with the stylus Wow
yes um it also has it has the options to
set it up for you know
3g what's the word I'm looking for
cellular service ah you could start it
data when you're off of Wi-Fi and it
also has things like keyboards that you
can attach to it you know and a stand
the props it up while you're typing so
there's other options you can get it
also lenovo of course is really good
about supporting things like corporate
images so if you have specific software
VPN security lock downs things like that
you can work with the company to
configure it for your for your own needs
it just sounds like they're doing
everything that rim tried to do would
apparently didn't get off the ground
right with the plane well I'm not
exactly sure about that because we
haven't tested it thoroughly yeah but I
did spend some time at the last night I
can tell you the stylist is pretty cool
it has handwriting recognition and it's
comfortable to take notes while you're
sitting on your lap okay it it supports
all the the shorthand that you would
expect a good handwriting recognition
app to to support the battery is also
pretty kick ass huh as far as tablets go
we don't hear that much yeah so you know
lenovo this is their business version
there's also the other one which is the
ideapad k 1 which is also an Android
tablet it came out a little bit earlier
we viewed we reviewed it last month and
we liked it this one you can expect a
full review on wire calm coming up next
week cool so next up we have Christina
Bonnington with a cute little robot that
was kind of like a marshmallow oh and
iPhone news right of course as I said
that's up it's another week in another
rumor mill going this is the mycoupon
robot it's based on a research robot
that's used for autism fair beam the
research robot is made by beatbox this
guy is made by a company called wild
stuff got two modes dance and touch and
it's got sensors on its head and all
over its body
it's also got advanced beat detection
software so it can dance to music super
cute and you can get them for under 50
bucks later this fall that was cute I
always loved PP soca marshmallows man
but actually the coolest thing about
this robot is that a portion of proceeds
go back to autism research that's nice
yeah the original robot is used for
autism research cool and this is just a
toy based on that one anyway uh speaking
of nothing that we were just talking
about that we have an obligatory Apple
rumor roundup yes tell me about
everything in that world because
everyone's dying to hear about it of
course absolutely so first off it looks
like t-mobile will definitely not be
getting that I found this year okay yeah
the network that didn't have it
continues to not have it yeah it's like
non-news but you know people still get
crazy over it i guess i don't upset a
lot of t mobile subscribers maybe so
maybe they'll defect to a one of the
other carriers right on what else next
it looks like the iphone is going to
land October fourth oh that's when the
next Apple event is so says some random
secret source that another news outlet
has exactly alright so October fourth
will keep a lookout eyes and ears open
we'll be there with bells on I'm sure
and then what else third thing ah Al
Gore was speaking at a summit earlier
this week and he said Al Gore like
secret robot Vice President Al Gore yes
former internet right yeah current Apple
board member algo yes what are you
saying so he instead so he was talking
you know it just gives us kind of
offhanded comment blah blah blah iPhones
next month so he said I felt I phone
plural plural yes mmm so you know
there's been rumors that there's an
iphone 4s and iPhone 5 so it just looks
maybe he knows something we don't he's
on the Apple board well that's like a
total Apple PR spin type you know you
casually drop something the former vice
president of the United States casually
drops a you know a hint in a conference
you know a speaking gig that's pretty
you know that's their style anyway all
right I'm sure you guys have had enough
of that what else you got you got a
something big in the world of robotics
and computing and hardware this week
happened what is it yes so this past
weekend was Maker Faire New York ok and
Arduino and atmel announced a couple of
new Arduino product ok what's an Arduino
product so an Arduino is it's a project
board as a microcontroller on it and you
can program it so you can use it in you
know robotics projects all sorts of
different things in the past I've used
one for my senior design project for
college for a solar-powered robot you're
gonna get grade yes although it did
terrible more competition but no did it
back down I don't want to talk about it
ok well we have an example of another
Arduino board that I got at Google's
developer conference earlier this year
is this somewhat like the new ones that
are coming out I mean it's it's similar
in that as an Arduino but the new one
the biggest announcement is the Arduino
do what doing what doing cuz they're
Italian exactly it is it has an ARM arm
architecture processors it does instead
of you normal and it's 32 32 bit also
and normally Arduino Tsar 8-bit ok so
it's going to be more complicated to
program arduino is rolling it out to a
select set of beta developers first
before they let just anyone use this guy
cool when when can we see a wider
release I believe early next year
yeah and then another cool product that
they announced is the order we know
Wi-Fi so they've had an Arduino Ethernet
shield for a while but now you'll be
able to like you know wirelessly and do
things so we yeah I always like wireless
okay thanks for stopping by and thank
you guys for watching again we'll see
you next week